community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
welcome back to las vegas now it is now
time to educate the next generation of
health care providers in southwest
medical the sponsors of this next
segment is on it but with some help take
a look
dr goldko nice to have you back dr hunt
introduce yourself and tell us why
you're here hi i'm dr tom hunt i'm a
family doctor and i'm the program
director for the valley health system
consortium family medicine residency
program
wow and dr golcol you know there's a
shortage of healthcare workers here in
nevada so we're partnering up to change
that how are we doing so
absolutely as our community so quickly
grows so does the demand on our health
care system to meet this challenge
several years ago the valley health
system partnered with southwest medical
largely under the guidance and
inspiration of dr hunt to create a
family medicine residency program right
here in southern nevada
before physicians become full-fledged
doctors they work as resident physicians
under the guidance of attending
physicians for three years
the program is now at its full capacity
with 30 residents and we're excited to
graduate our first class of primary care
physicians in june of this year dr hunt
this is the largest medical family here
so let's talk about the driving force
you know in starting this residency
program
well you know unfortunately as many of
us know nevada ranks oftentimes at the
bottom of many health care indicators
when you look at primary care doctors
per capita in other words per 100 000 in
nevada we rank 48th according to john
packham who's up at unr and does the
statistics on this
uh we have more than mississippi but uh
most other states are way ahead of us
about a quarter of our doctors in our uh
community actually have trained outside
of the country and three out of every 10
physicians in nevada are over the age of
60. um so we are in for a tsunami of
physicians leaving the workforce we need
more doctors here
wow and dr hunt again um tell us more
about the partners within the program
well we have some very great partners
you know the valley health system is our
sponsoring institution and they had the
foresight to see we really need more
primary care doctors family doctors
specifically in order to provide better
care to our patients they reached out to
optum and southwest medical and together
we've created
as you said the largest family medicine
residency program in the country
and dr hunt what type of what type of
care is given within the clinic
great question you know we're family
doctors and we're trained quite broadly
so that we can take care of everybody
from newborns to your
95 year old grandmother we take care of
a lot of prevention immunizations making
sure people have cancer screening we
take care of people when they get sick
we do lumps and bumps we remove things
from the skin high blood pressure
diabetes cholesterol when you think
about it um we're a one-stop shop and if
we can't take care of it we'll find the
right doctor for you to uh
help
we also focus a lot on managing any
kinds of infections such as covalent and
post-covet so our residency and our
family medicine clinic is set up for
everything
well thank you both for everything
you're doing for our community dr gokul
why is this such an important program
and partnership for us here in las vegas
and nevada our residents here are able
to immerse themselves within the
community they get to know the
healthcare system the healthcare
resources and especially the patient
population here in need with their
primary care physicians as their guides
and their attendings they're able to
immerse themselves as integral parts of
the care team and really help provide
that comprehensive care to patients
thank you again to southwest medical for
being one of our community pride
partners las vegas now we'll be right
back